good
hello everyone my name is Lawrence
founder at the companion the
companion I think that's the first time
I've ever said that in public I
sometimes say it to the team so you
could tell I'm I'm pumped um and because
I'm also today's host for a very special
Stargate celebration I think this is
going to be the largest Stargate fandom
collaboration in history and I hope
actually this will be the first of many
more to come now this event is being
broadcast live on five YouTube channels
including the Stargate OG gate world
with Darren an absolutely incredible
Stargate resource David at dial the gate
David is another OG in the Stargate
fandom and also some newer folks
including Jay and Matt from sidet trk
and my favorite gals Stargate gals
Rebecca and Athena Tano at three fry
Shore and of course is being broadcast
also on the companion otherwise how
would I be talking to you
now oh the live chats from every channel
are being pulled through to our screens
here so we can see them so make sure you
leave lots of lovely comments and I do
want to say there are many other amazing
partners and friends that we couldn't
quite fit into this one event so if you
love what we're doing today we'd love to
start a new tradition to be able to
bring those friends into future
celebrations but focusing on today if
you're not familiar with any one of the
channels or podcasts or websites I just
mentioned please please check them out
and if you like what they do subscribe
and follow their channels you know the
classic saying the rising Atlantis tide
lifts all puddle jumpers is that right
or is it the rising tide lifts all no no
I think I was right before the rising
Atlantis tide lifts all puddle jumpers
it's cleaner that way so I I want to
kick off the event first by bringing in
our guest of honor the companions
creative adviser my mentor Brad
Wright hey Lawrence Brad how are you I'm
good man I'm good I join I have all this
this this uh setup of uh in my office
with microphones and and cameras and uh
and we defaulted to the iPad because it
was the only thing that worked but here
I am I'm pretty sure this happens every
time we do something yeah not not on
your side my no I think it was my fault
again okay okay probably a button I
didn't press or something oh it's gonna
be really fun this is what it is it's a
celebration it's a party who knows what
gonna happen a dog will wander through
in the background I'm
sure um well Brad like all events that
we've done together I know fans will
inevitably ask you about you know a new
Stargate they're holding out hope that
you're going to be at the helm and you
may know you may not know there's been a
lot of talk right now that Amazon has a
panel today a New York ComiCon and you
know there's always going to be
speculation is there new Stargate or
some kind of announcement so I wanted to
First give you the floor to clear up
anything about what we can say or can't
say and obviously we can talk about it
now well you know I
mean MGM did call me to write a pilot
for a new
Stargate four years ago now and then a
whole bunch of things happened that were
out of you know out of my control and
even out of mgm's control and um and
when MGM was purchased by Amazon it was
like after the the the pilot I had
written had been been sitting on the
shelf all through the
pandemic and Amazon is a different
company so they were thinking bigger and
so they are very likely to uh to want
Stargate as one of their 10 polls I mean
it just makes sense it's a an MGM
property that you know did very well for
them and still does very well for them
um but they'll probably want to go
bigger and they're not Consulting me
like nobody's phoning me and say hey
Brad what do you think so I get that it
makes sense it's not the old MGM uh uh
so I'm in the dark in fact some of the
people who are going to be asking me
questions today I I think know more
about what's going on withon that I do
so uh you know I I'm
I'm cautious to say anything because
maybe they will call me but uh they
haven't yet and uh and that's fine it's
their property they own it and it's not
like I haven't done my share of Stargate
so I'm fine with it I'm very happy that
it will continue and we I don't know
when it will continue or let Forum
probably a movie but um I haven't got a
call yet even about that so so uh
you know I'm as in the dark but also
eager to see what happens as as
everybody else well you know through our
conversations and emails and exchanges I
Am Hash team Brad not to say like I
would hate you know any kind of new
Stargate or MGM or anything but we are
always here to support you at least I'm
here to support you right you know that
um I do okay all right it's nice it's
nice that we have it's nice that there
this there's this ongoing online thing
about you know me being involved but I
also have to say and I say this every
time it was never just me guys it was it
was you know Jonathan Rob Cooper has an
enormous impact on this show Paul and
Joe car binder Martin g a whole bunch of
people a whole whack of people made
Stargate not just
me no for sure um okay well so Brad I'm
gonna give you a quick rundown um and
I'm going to give the viewers a quick
rundown of how today is going to work
since there's a a lot of people waiting
to join us in the back um and this is
going to be around an 89 minute event is
that right Brad 89 yes yes 89 minutes
make sure start eight minutes late I'm
have to go
fast um so basically we're gonna start
off with a 10-minute Roundtable
discussion with you and all the other
channel Partners I'm going to then take
everyone backstage and I'll bring each
channel uh back on one by one and
they'll each have 15 minutes with you uh
to interview you uh except for us the
companion uh we're only going to take 10
minutes in order to make that 89 minute
math work as my promise to you um and I
also know some of the channels um had
had some of their fans send in questions
or they might have you know unique kind
of uh little segments that I want to
give anything away so um that that might
happen um but essentially each Channel
and their Community uh will have a
dedicated 15 minutes with you and for
the purposes of um hosting the event
when there's a about a minute left in
each segment I'll like kind of pop back
in my head will pop in and kind of give
people a little one minute counter and
then bring in the next Channel sound
good sure all right so time to bring in
our panelists and this will be in the
order in which the segments um are gonna
happen Okay so first up we have Jay and
Matt from sidet
Trek hey guys and next up we've got
Rebecca and Athena Tano from three fries
short
hi Rebecca and Christina
hello and then we've got David Reid from
dial the
gate hello sir good to see you again
there you are your face was frozen for
the longest time oh no can you hear me
okay yeah I can hear you
fine and of course we've got Darren from
gate World Darren hey hi
everyone all right thank you so much for
joining and being part of the first ever
Stargate celebration pretty cool
right um so everyone here loves the show
um that you created Brad all these years
ago so first Brad I'd love to know your
experience um well I love to hear your
experience uh as to how almost like this
entire industry of Online Entertainment
as you can see has been created that's
been spun off of your show if you have
any thoughts on that it's interesting
because uh when Stargate began um
we were like going online and seeing
things but you had to go to news groups
you know you had to really work for it
you had it was not just uh and and then
you know I think one of the there was
star sg.com for MGM and then gate
world popped up and it was this thing
that we you know it was like hey what a
gate World thing it was this cool thing
and so nearly from the beginning there
was this growing online presence and
then but the Shocker and I don't even
know shockra is the wrong word but the
the I maybe the cool thing about it is
that it has continued the life of
Stargate online has continued long long
after the show and you know I people are
constantly it's it trained yesterday on
X I want to call it Twitter but it's I
guess it's X but it was trending and um
that's pretty cool all by
itself because it's been a while since
we were on the air yeah I think that
shows the kind of love and um you know
admiration basically the Legacy that
you've you've created really um so
Darren I'm going to go to you first um
can you tell us a little bit about like
what Brad was alluding to you know the
origin of gate world and you started
popping up and and really how far it's
come right it's still the source for G
you know Stargate it's been a really
amazing ride to be honest gate world is
celebrating its 24th birthday in a
couple of weeks right so it's uh it's
been the majority of my adult life um my
I don't even have any children that are
that age yet uh but because we're
talking about fandom and we're talking
about history I I want to start by
giving a shout out to the website that
preceded gate World there was a big fan
site Brad I don't know if you remember
this I think it was sg1 domnet and it
was a it was a high school kid and MGM
ended up basically buying his site and
bringing him on and then he he had a set
visit in SE
four and then remember that I don't
remember his name there were pictures I
can't remember his name I apologize if
he's watching but uh the story was he
went off to film school and MGM bought
his site and as these things tend to
happen it disappeared and it was kind of
lost to Internet history so I've been
really proud that Gator world has
survived as long as it has in part
because well number one because of
Brad's support and the support of the
studio the support of MGM and everybody
up at Bridge we couldn't do what we do
if we didn't have their support my first
set visit was in season
8 um and if we didn't have people who
wanted to you know watch the show and
then come online and talk about it and
read news and maybe even some spoilers
now and again uh so it's been an
incredible right it's been really
wonderful thanks D 24 years that's
amazing you're were a kid you had to be
a kid when you started I was I was one
year out of college
I think I was
23 wow all right oh it's awesome well
David I know you've been also a pretty
big force in Gate world too but I wanted
to ask you really about your channel
dial the gate and I can't believe it's
onto season three already awesome and
the finale is coming up with Michael
Shanks in a few weeks so anyone likes
Michael Shanks check that out so David
yeah tell us about gate world oh I'm
sorry dial the gate dial the gate um I
you know I was actually Brad was one of
the reasons why I started this thing
because he and I had been talking about
uh doing some content way back I
actually got to sit down and interview
him at gatecon I'm still hoping that
that interview is going to be coming out
like an hour and a half interview that
it was a it was a great 90 minutes and
you know when when coid happened I was
like I was spending a lot of time on
YouTube and I discovered the archive of
American television which is this
amazing uh
free uh library of just interviews from
everyone in the business and they were
they were like Joe Rogan format at the
time they were two and three hours long
and we're we're we're nearing you know a
few months into Co and it's like now all
these actors are being so many of them
are leites are being forced to learn
Zoom so that was the end where it was
like we can just sit down and and I can
start archiving these stories um through
YouTube for the world and for free and
we're now at I'll I'll be clearing the
hurdle of 230 episodes this this uh
month and we're finishing with Michael
Shanks so it's it's been an enormous
amount of material uh and uh I'm so
thankful to everyone who has contributed
to it because it has it has just changed
my life and changed how I look at this
show that I thought I knew so well and
someone other so many people come on who
just expand that that uh uh Corpus of of
knowledge so we're we're busy
transcribing all these episodes right
now but uh Brad I'd still love to have
you on oneon-one you know I I at when
you first asked me it was right in the
heat of everything that was happening
with with uh and I there was literally
nothing I felt I could talked about yeah
in the current time because I then I
thought well it's still going to happen
cuz then GM still wanted it to happen
and and uh you know and then things
started going away and and then I didn't
want to talk about it right and I don't
blame I'm okay now I'm okay now okay
yeah have you seen any any of the work
that we did with with Rob and some of
the others I saw I saw the one with Paul
and Joe I saw the one with Rob I watched
it it was cool yeah you know way more
about the
show well I'm I'm so thankful to the
journey that you provided all of us and
one of the things that I was uh I'll be
real quick is in discovering is that you
know you guys created content that meant
something but especially in talking to
rob that wasn't necessarily the goal you
guys were just entertaining people yeah
and you know that's really the
perspective that I've taken on
so thank you Brad David's catching up to
you you know he's going to hit that 300
episode Mark
soon that's true that's make that's the
only
difference Jay and Matt it feels like
just yesterday uh we first started
hearing about sidet track um and what
it's been been three years now is that
right um Jay what made you first want to
get started in this
space I I started my first YouTube
channel during coid because I had
nothing better to do and uh so but I was
talking about like Mysteries and things
and nobody watched and it was and I was
started to get like people get really
angry at me because we didn't always
agree with like
their version of the story so I thought
no instead of having this YouTube
channel where people shout at me why
don't I talk about something I love and
I start so I started talking about
sci-fi um and we were able to monetize
the channel in like six weeks it took me
like two years to monetize my first
channel but uh and then just through
sheer look we started to get some
information that was like just really
cool information about what was going on
with Stargate and a few other things but
um for me I just love talking about
stuff that I love and Brad right thank
was a big part of my favorite show ever
made and that I still watch there's like
Stargate sg1 I've just finished watching
Atlantis so I've watched both of those
this year I'm G to watch SGU next and
then Travelers is also on my list and
then I watch Firefly maybe twice a year
and those are basically the shows I
watch over and over um to the point
where um I I can virtually go word for
word which is just sad but
it's sad is it's not sad very it's
glorious but I mean yeah your words are
literally engrained in my brain which is
but um I when I started this channel two
years ago though I just do I was doing
it for fun and now I'm sat on a panel
with dialating gate world and just
talking to is just I don't
how about you um how did you get
involved with
Sidetrack uh so I joined 18 months ago
which Jay reminded me of today which I
didn't think it was that long but it was
um initially just because I noticed he
had no sort of like community so I I
just reached out to him was like you
don't have a Discord server you don't
have this and that do you want me to
sell it up for you and he was like yeah
I don't know how to do that work
so I I I came on as the technical
support started making a few videos I go
on the lives every single week um for me
it's all about the community so being
here with all of you is fantastic and
seeing all these comments in in the in
the sidebar is really good really nice
uh but yeah just talking about like
Stargate in general is my favorite thing
to do people who know me at work get
annoyed that I talk about starget as
much as I
do my my family I talk about it
constantly um but they're not laughing
now no they're not laughing
now all right and we're gonna move on to
um to my gals um but let's start with
Rebecca she you know her day job is a
producer at the
companion but not tonight uh because I
think she's a secret spy and co-host of
the brilliant three fr short
podcast um and so I see just three fry
short I think in general as like this
part of this newer generation of
Stargate fandom content creator I don't
mean because your podcast is newer but
really I feel like you're leading the
charge I guess in this kind of Stargate
Tick Tock you know kind of community um
lots of followers and if you aren't on
Tik Tok or you need to find a friendly
place a Stargate friendly place
um uh yeah Thea Tano and Rebecca that is
those are the people that you should
find leading that charge and so uh you
know Rebecca how I guess how has your
journey been over the last three years
on that that really interesting question
I've answered it a lot um I'll try to
answer it really concisely since I have
answered it so many times but um let's
see I got Co and I decided to do a
rewatch of Stargate sg1 in December of
2020 and while I was sick sitting on the
couch I was looking at Tik Tok and I was
like I wonder if Stargate stuff is on
Tik Tok and sure enough it was and that
led me to Christina and to Sarah who are
my we call each other co- fries at three
fries short that's good um and that led
us to connecting with the companion um
we were able to record a video for you
Brad and Rick for the celebration uh uh
what a year ago a little more than a
year ago yeah and um not long after that
um and I think you even said to Lawrence
hire them and um he did uh so I I I get
to work at the companion now it's opened
so many um opportunities for us even on
the podcast um and it's been wonderful
just to see that whole progression and I
think Christine and I would both say
that uh we have done things now in our
two plus two and a half years of our
podcast that we never would have
imagined uh We've interviewed people we
never could have imagined so it's been a
crazy two and a half threeyear ride for
us I would
say
cool well BR I'm not sure if you're
familiar with um Tik Tok I know you do
those dances sometimes off camera yeah
yeah I'm I'm all over Tik Tok it's just
not my face it's yeah yeah it's the
moves yeah just m and I thought um
obviously Christina you can talk about
anything you'd like to introduce
yourself but if you can also describe to
Brad what Stargate Tik Tok as an
experience is like I'm sure we'd all
love to know
oh gosh okay um let me think about this
so Stargate Tik Tok is this carved out
space where I think a bunch of like
quiet nerds showed up dipped their toe
in and like we're just experiencing the
app because we're trying to figure out
what it was and I feel like everyone's
kind of stumbled onto each other kind of
like when you show up to like a high
school dance and everyone's in the
middle and then quietly like the
antisocial people go like off to the
wall and they're like just watching and
then everyone just huddles up and makes
friends against the wall I feel like
that's how I found the community it's
just kind of I didn't know why I was on
there but I was just kind of going along
for the ride and then I made a couple
posts just trying to be on Trend but
then Tik Tok said oh you love Stargate
here's all your other Stargate people
and started like sending them to me and
that's what it feels like it feels like
everyone who's there to have a good time
who wants to be engaged she's
appreciative of community and but we
have our thing and we have our own
little niche way of doing it and so
whether you're a cosplayer or you're a
commentary or whether you're someone who
just wants to watch and like make
friends it's all welcome and there's no
expectations and I think that's really
cool um and that's what that Community
is on Tik Tok um so we don't really
great we don't do a ton of the dances
you don't to do the dances to be a part
of it um but that's where we grew from
so myself and Sarah who can't be here
are predominantly commentators and gave
a lot of like rewatch critique and then
from that community was they ask you
guys should do a podcast and then that's
when Rebecca came on and said hey I can
help produce I've got and we had already
had commentary so it is a community
asked podcast that we really just
stumbled on said sure we'll do it and
through authenticity and this fandom
have become where we are now and we're
just along for the ride and enjoying
every bit of it so that's that's best
way to put
it all right so I'm I'm glad Brad now
you got to know everyone a little bit I
mean you've known some of us for many
years like Darren and David decades um
so we're gonna all kind of go backstage
now um in the first kind of interview
segment now we'll be with um Jay and
Matt citrek uh and then hopefully I'll
see you in 15 or so minutes all
[Music]
right oh that was good that's better
than ass
I I like is pretty good they
know that was dope um we'll just get
stuck straight into it if you can
because we've got 15 minutes and I feel
this it's going to go quite quickly so
can I throw the first question jump in
man cool right so um it's me first shut
up M um so Star Trek has shown us that
keeping Cannon straight is actually
quite hard apparently and Star Wars at
times Stargate was always really good at
it though and I always we always talk
about how keeping the cannon was always
really good in Stargate there's not many
times I think he made
mistakes um how did you keep it all
straight you know setting all these
rules up and things and were there any
times that you can think of that it
nearly went horribly wrong
or actually the the first time it went
horribly horribly wrong was in the
opening scene of the pilot but I've told
that story uh uh Ste through and and
then steep back and we went he do that
and so that you know we fixed it sort of
not really
um the reason the reason we were pretty
good at continuity is because we had a a
team of writers and
directors that had
uh so enjoyed working together that we
just stayed for the longest time I mean
I left this this I don't know of many
cases if any where this has happened
before but I left the show for a bit and
came back like I came and went and
because I needed to recharge and and
spent more than a few days with my
family and but I came back and it was oh
hey Brad come back in and I would always
spin stories and because it was me Rob
for the you know almost the entire show
Rob came on as a story editor early
early early on I think we were shooting
the pilot so he from the
beginning
um and so there's that continuity and
then and then Paul and Joe came on and
season 4 and so somebody basically would
just raise their hand Whenever there was
an issue Whenever there was like oh wait
a minute can't do that you know and
sometimes we would go have we broken
that is that a rule can we do that and
then we'd say sure and so that's when
you create new Canon because you're not
contradicting anything um but I think it
was just the continuity of um the
continuity of of uh writers and
directors because on set occasionally
somebody a director would say well let's
try this and you know somebody would say
no you can't do that with a staff weapon
you know it doesn't work that way it
just does this and uh and and so that
was very helpful just the rules of going
back and forth through a Stargate is
it's really handy when everybody knows
what those rules are and and you don't
have to explain it to this to a new
director because time is money in that
situation yeah
I mean even when you went over to SG
Atlantis and then SGU it was sort of an
extension of that team it always felt it
was you knew it was you know you watched
the crew and it was like I know him from
there Rob and I step both stepped back
in the last two years of Atlantis uh a
little bit I mean I came I kept coming
in and helped break stories and I wrote
a couple I think um the shrine happened
in a year that I that I wasn't uh on
fully but that was also to help free
some time to develop and come up with
something new because MGM was saying
we're going to need what the next thing
is and and uh for whatever reason
Atlantis had a hard time um in terms of
the business model going Beyond season
five I I that was a f you know that was
a business model issue more than
anything else MGM was imploding at the
time there always I mean well they were
you know that it was scary it was scary
and and when they did implode it was It
was kind of heartbreaking because people
I knew people I had talked to for years
and I would phone and it would be so and
so no longer works at MGM and you'd go
oh do you have a number so and so no
longer works at MGM that's all they
would
say um and uh so yeah it was kind of sad
and and of course we saw it coming in
the last season of universe and it was
like the Titanic heading toward the
iceberg he was like oh [__] we're gonna
hit that
Iceberg just no way around it it was it
was a slow motion Perfect Storm well it
was heartbreaking for fans when it
happened it was uh and now MGM basically
doesn't
exist I mean they certainly do exist as
a brand and as a
library um and there are people who work
at MGM now uh some of them have even
some of even the new people who I met to
uh when they asked me to write a pilot
have moved on so um uh but MGM is one of
the most recognized able brands in the
world to this day uh so that's you know
when when Amazon buys something it's
more than just a library it's it's that
line yeah I saw my first movie last
night that was MGM um it's so called
killing something it's quite good
actually but it was Amazon MGM Studios
really first one I've seen yeah
interesting interesting it was a moment
I had to pause it like that's a moment
need to remember that but anyway Matt do
you jump in I do I
do oh sorry out of time no I'm
kidding you stopping reach the screen
and grab you if you
tried you mentioned starget Universe
there um which is probably my favorite
of the three um how much of a plan was
there for Stargate Universe um how much
can you tell us about where they would
have gone had you well it all it all had
to do ultimately with with the mystery
and the and the destiny original Mission
and and rush and and twin Destinies in
the second um I mean that was intended
to launch a whole new arc um because at
the end of twin
Destinies the crew basically get sent to
another timeline and and and and we're
going to
create as we see in epilog and and
Beyond a whole a whole bunch of humans
that we could run into um who would join
in our Quest um and help you know keep
the destiny afloat and alive and going
and uh the transition was
always supposed to be and I think one of
the problems with the show is we took
too long to do this it was supposed to
be the wrong people in in on the ship
like totally this these people are not
supposed to be here and and and then
jelling over the course of a period of
time to become exactly the right people
to do the mission and and uh and that
mission ultimately was to find out um
the the uh what the Ancients perceived
as uh as something that evidence of an
intelligence that existed before the Big
Bang um which which had some spiritual
uh uh impact on some people but but also
a science point of view um and then of
course the other fun thing about that
is um uh the Ancients clearly figured
that out or they would have or or they
would have gone to Destiny they launched
the ship hoping to do this and then went
oh we got it probably because they
ascended I imag it was because they
ascended yeah
looked but but we haven't ascended and
so the the the idea of the human
humankind taking over that mantle for
our own purposes I I thought was always
really
interesting would you have had um so you
mentioned the descendants of the the the
original CR that went back in time would
you have had those join Destiny at some
point well we we certainly already
encountered them and I and because they
moved on from that planet uh I had hoped
that we would see seeds of them uh
elsewhere in the in the next galaxy when
we arrived there G Eli was going to fix
the ship and and we and we were going to
emerge into a Galaxy where there were
also humans and they were our own
descendants which is kind of cool I just
thought that was really cool ni I
remember the moment pitching when I
pitched that idea on the phone I was in
Arizona for some reason I was on on the
phone with Robert and and uh and Paul
and Joe and they went cool we can shoot
humans because I was always objecting to
the fact that if we're a million
galaxies away why do we have why why
would we run into humanoids that's why
every every body was so alien when we
met
them the main question we got when we
asked this out to fans was will we get
conclusion T you will we get and it's
the question I know you obviously we we
have no way of knowing but it is
probably the most thing we're asked you
know me I get asked a lot too uh and and
whoever takes over the
show may not even want to you know
continue in Canon but if they do I'm
pretty sure they have to answer that
question what happen happened yeah there
I have come up with lots of ways uh and
in my pilot uh script address the issue
um oh it's a good way for now you
address the issue that's gonna get
people asking questions well I don't
want to say what I did because whoever
does it might want to do something like
that and I don't want to I don't want to
put it out there I mean in some ways
it's kind of an obvious
solution put it in your Memoir tell us
in your Memoir maybe yeah I'll put it in
my Memoir Jay as long as you just I
can't write a memoir because I don't
remember enough be I don't know I was
working it's a I can tell you about
happened at my kid's birthday party that
year but I can't the show is a blur
doing 22 or episodes that must have just
been I mean we hear I hear stories about
you know writing literally writing and
then filming next day and things like
this and just that it was just we were
actually pretty good at staying ahead I
I was I was uh I was a big big believer
of giving the crew and still am a big
believer in giving the crew time to prep
a script because you can't build the
sets we were building uh with a script
that you get it you know during prep you
I was developing story ideas with the
art Department I wouldn't just I would
the so a writer would say what did we do
this this and this and I would go down
to the art department or for that matter
go down to the visual effects department
and say can we do this if we do this
let's consider doing this and then we
that would be too expensive and so we
would say okay well let's build this for
this show but be able to repurpose the
structure for this show and you probably
for the most part don't even didn't even
know what we had done that but but
preparation in producing as a wrer
producer uh puts money on the screen uh
and and keeps your crew alive uh having
said that your lead way goes away right
you start with 10 scripts or however
many scripts and you think they're in
great shape but then when you read them
when you okay time to do a pass on this
script you go oh [__] I have to rewrite
this thing completely and it has
generally less to do with the with the
Mecha mechanism of the show the
mechanics of the show than it does just
the characters and the
dialogue there's a there's a ton of
Stargates where I remember writing
scenes and I'll see it I go I remember
writing that scene and then the episode
will the credit will happen or I'll go
back and see what the credit was oh I I
guess I didn't write that one or I did
but my name is
not sure job is to rewrite and make sure
that the characters all have the same
voices and and and for production and
something you think will be a great
script at the beginning of prep isn't
necessarily going to work by the time
you're in August and you don't have the
money you thought you
would I think it was actually Star Trek
I was thinking about that they were I
heard stories about them literally
writing scripts the day before and then
sending them off I'm watching and Brent
Spiner saying I got script one night and
you were filming the next day and he was
like I'm supposed to learn 30 pages and
like you know mad no [__] happens and
and and I I've been in the situation
where I've had to write for the next day
I mean you know an actor gets a pentis
or something you have to you have to
make changes you have
to you have to make changes on the de on
the fly or one of your actors fall over
this and HS his ankle or something who
knows yeah sh Happ these things happen
um we wanted to ask a question sort of
get a feeling of of a bit more about you
and what sort of thing you still watch
now so if you got the if you got the
chance to write an episode for something
that was on TV now or sci-fi or anything
really what sort of show do you think
what would you love to like oh I'd love
to write an episode for
that well that's not really a fair
question because I think you know the
answer is Star Trek uh I I I got into
this business I got into this business
uh in part so I could write for Next
Generation
and I really wanted to write for that
show I thought it was the best show on
TV and and uh so when Terry metalis did
season three of a card I was so jealous
because I thought that ship had sailed
and then I told him so I I I I sent him
a message and said man you just did my
dream and and you did it really great
you did it better than I would have so
congratulations but yeah if if anybody
asked me to write I don't care which
Star Trek I like them all I I would do
that in a heartbeat it's not going to
happen but it I would do
it it's not going to happen because you
don't bring in somebody from the outside
uh as a freelancer anymore it just
doesn't happen anymore it used to but it
doesn't
anymore two minutes Matt are gone
two so I got the question other than Z
the Z nicel with the three shot rule is
there any other part of Stargate law
that you would have reconed in
hindsight
probably
honestly there's a bunch of stuff uh
that that
just you know you you you
uh you R we ran through a lot of trees
you know because you you think you write
exterior and you have to you can't shoot
everything in the studio but you know
it's it's
just
uh at the end of the day I mean and and
I wish I wish I could remove a couple of
episodes just from from the show like
like emancipation is terrible we don't
want it's terrible I know it is I'm not
D I knew then I was like oh this is
gonna kill us but um it it it's you
can't you can't rewrite history i' I've
done a series about that too by the way
uh and uh but you can't do it in real I
love Travelers Travelers is one my show
I'm very proud of it it's a good show I
love that nobody noticed that that looks
like a penis
did you just didn't realize yeah nobody
noticed no never Ur to me Michael Shanks
told us thing we
got no we got two really quick fire
questions from fans so one TKO bat asked
us um how's your handicap these
days it's down to a 13 index that's not
bad that's pretty good that's pretty
good I shot 82 yesterday oh that's very
good it's pretty good mine's rubish like
three or something it's a it's a hard
game man it's a hard game it really
irritates me I hit the ball and it goes
to two o'clock so I think I'll aim over
at 10 o'clock then it still goes to two
o'clock no you just need to adjust your
grip J we'll talk about that another
time yeah yeah anyway last one last one
this is from gray gray gray Hammer I
think I've said that right um what do
the furlings actually look like because
we all have the image in of evil Ewok
little ew that's yeah okay sure that's
what it is here's here's
how Robert was writing episode called
the fifth race and he wanted it to be
the fifth race because it sounded cooler
than the fourth race so as he was
listing the things we we okay the Knox
okay the you know he he needed another
name and he came up with the furlings
and I remember reading the script I went
furlings who the hell are the furlings
any I needed another name that is the
extent of of their creation true story
which is why we mocked it so much in the
200th episode or the hund whichever it
was so the fings are basically whatever
we think they look like sure sure and
and if you think that we sat around
going I think the berlings are this or
that no no no it was Rob needed another
name and that's what it
was coming up with alien names is not
always
easy probably regretted that one we said
the fings should be the villains in the
new show when it ever comes out so we we
joke about the evil Ewoks quite a lot I
yeah sure sure okay it's probably not a
very good idea but uh to to make
everybody furry in a in a television
show but those poor
actors yes
exactly thank you so so much for that
astonishing 15 minutes is not long in a
Florence I ha
you well I mean I will lose my voice by
the end of this so you got first at
least so yeah great to
meet I watch your stuff uh you know more
about uh what's going on MGM than I do
and I appreciate the Insight so thank
you no thank you that s amazing for you
to say yeah we've been very very lucky
just stupidly but thank you so much all
right thanks guys see you all right and
so next up we've got three fries
[Music]
short hello
hi that has a really cool logo by the
way I love it it's adorable um we quite
like our theme song as well um so we are
three fry short and you may have noticed
there are only two of us here right now
so um you're one fry short we're one fry
short yes um so we wanted to play a
video from Sarah she has a question for
you so we just kick it off with that
first if Tommy Can can do that for
us hello and welcome to the segment of
three fres short unearthing the Stargate
I'm your co- fres Sarah who could not be
there today so three fres short will
actually be one fres short of being
three fres short I guess or something
like that something we've discussed on
our podcast is how Stargate came around
at a very particular time when meta arcs
were becoming the norm with TV how
everything was tied together as one big
plot line for a season so with sg1 we
got a really good mix of story of the
Week episodes but then episodes that
were also tied into bigger plot lines we
went to a lot of of Worlds and met a lot
of characters that were just a one-time
thing and we never saw them again like
what fate amoka man and Ergo and it was
really a pleasant surprise when a world
or characters would return kind of out
of the blue like the Tolan was super
surprised when they came back or the
robots from Tin Man I truly never
thought we would ever see them again and
when they had their follow-up episode my
mind was blown so my question for you
Brad is are there any plot lines or
characters that you wish you could have
Revisited or developed more than you
just couldn't get
to
huh I guess uh we we always created a
characters or a
character um with the intention of
adding to the
mythology the uh what fedo moroka guy uh
uh N I think his character name was I
cannot believe I remember that
I'm if that is maybe I didn't remember
know I don't know either
so uh I mean his story was so personal
and small it was he wanted to know you
know his basically what happened to his
mate with the other person in his life
so that story felt complete whenever a
story feels
complete it's over right so and that's
cool but I mean I I I wanted to do
another
um another
um another you know what I didn't want
to say specifically because there was a
lot that we planned or it could have
going forwards the nature of the
structure of how we did Stargate is how
I like to do TV which is I call it it's
like a hybrid yes modern storytelling is
one big
story but even the best versions of that
like the last of us do spectacular
one-off
episodes um
that that are a a window into the larger
picture this is this story this personal
intimate story that expands on a
character builds builds the world from
the from a character perspective and and
so those are important to me and and uh
the fact that we managed to
um continually remind ourselves of of a
thread that we needed to you know to
pick up on that we had left at the pre
at the end of a previous season it would
be what we would do at the end of each
season you would say okay we have to
revisit this this this and this I think
we're good about this I that story feels
over doesn't it and you know that's
basically how it happened
um I I I can't think of another specific
one that I would love to you know Tom
jows was you know was just fun I said we
we did the Ergo character I think tar
valenza pitched the S the the story for
Ergo and I said we would need like and
Peter was a consultant writer and
director at the time and he said like my
dad and I went yeah can he would he do
it he said yeah I'll ask him and that
was that so I I don't know
if I mean he he expended so much energy
in
that uh performance I don't know that he
would uh he would have come back anyway
but uh that story was told you know what
I mean the story told sure
absolutely yeah um so kind of a
follow-up to that is and you mentioned
this a little bit just earlier with um
Sidetrack is there's some episodes that
you like I wish I could just get away
with I think we all agree about
emancipation but on a note what are some
storylines that maybe went past their
expiration date in your mind and you
would have liked to have wrapped them up
sooner and then what's your process when
you're like I need to be done with this
I want to be done with this but you have
to you have to wind it down um is there
a storyline within Stargate that you
would have wrapped
sooner by the end of season 7 uh we
thought we were ending the
show every season we thought this would
be the last season and so we we found
ourselves wrapping up story lines and uh
you know defeating the gold I mean they
are kind of
defeated people talk about the new show
and who will be the ghoul well we kind
of defeated the ghoul there're they're
they're um so I was kind of happy to
move beyond that villain the the villain
that we create didn't really create we
borrowed from the feature uh we just
said that raw was a go and
um
um and it it's fun creating new villains
Rob came up with the orai entirely on
his own uh when um as a uh as a new
villain for season 8 and n
n and 10 of um of sg1 because he felt we
needed a new one and and I think I think
whatever the new Amazon series or movie
is I think it will lead a new one I
think a new villain is necessary unless
they do a reboot
absolutely absolutely did I answer that
question I think so I think because what
I get from that is you would have liked
to wrap the Gould up much sooner and try
to keep killing them off um because to
your point I think the orai were a great
villain and they only had a short window
of time and so we got their continuation
through the like movies that came but um
it's interesting to hear that because
now that I think of it in that
perspective they do the goule just they
keep dying and coming back and it is
yeah it does get a little rinsed out
well TK was one of our main characters
and he was excuse
me he was tied in I mean he was the
first Prime he was tied into that
world so for his sake alone it was it
was important that they be around for a
long time and they were so dominant in
our galaxy for the longest time but you
know by the time we were moving on to
other galaxies and I remember even
objecting to that going we can't just go
to another galaxy the galaxyy is
enormous you can't just leap around
galaxies and then we ended up doing but
um um I thought I thought uh the a new
enemy uh maybe I'm telling you a little
bit about my pilot uh should come from
another Galaxy um and uh and if they
have uh access to this one uh uh maybe
there's a whole new story that could
happen there uh yes I'm telling you
about the pilot I wrote that'll never
see
[Laughter]
probably tell any more say more no say
more it's just it's just us here
nobody's listening there's nobody out
there feels that way I know I love this
though um that was really exciting we
won't I won't push that question because
I know that we won't go that far because
I love to hear about it but be super
mindful of it um but yeah Rebecca so you
you kind of answered one of my questions
about the um pros and cons to those
those plot structures the kind of story
of the week um versus The Meta plot
because there there seems to be a lot of
backlash especially in Star in Star Trek
um with the new Trek versus um you know
everybody's like strange new worlds is
great because it's story of the week
versus you know discovery card or
something that has that overarching Arch
so um I I think you kind of talked you
touched on that hybrid thing let let me
add to that because the rationale for it
is I believe that um that the the uh the
person who who just checks in for one
episode deserves a story they don't
deserve a chapter in a book they deserve
a story like if you miss an episode of
whatever you deserve to sit down and
have something that has a beginning and
a middle and end and this is the story
does it tie into the larger Arc
hopefully maybe absolutely but I think
it's important I think it's very
important that the constant viewer get
rewarded with a large Arc and the
frequent if not slightly infrequent
viewer gets a story when they tune in I
think that's only fair it's kind of like
trying to jump into to a comic book
character or something you have no idea
where to go yeah also also um I've
watched shows that I have enjoyed and
liked and and missed an episode or two
and going what the hell is going on I
don't what I don't even what what did I
miss I missed one episode how did how
the hell is this happening and I don't
think that's cool I think um well it is
cool when you when you when you're
binging it and you watch everything but
I just think I just think uh maybe it's
the way my brain is wired I I think in
terms of story so when I come up with an
episode I it has a story yes it ties
into the larger AR but it also has a
story sure I love that um I'm G to move
right into this next question here which
is uh we did a whole episode on tropes
in Stargate um tropes tropes yeah so the
the question was do you have a favorite
Trope and or a least favorite Trope um
and have you ever upended a Trope to
like taken it and just completely
flipped it upside down uh I can't think
of a specific example but I I think that
that was what we were trying to do a lot
I mean the the the truth is in science
fiction somebody pitches an idea and you
go yeah but that was this or St Tre did
this and because I'm such a huge sci-fi
nerd I I I would also go to books and
say yeah ASO did that or whatever
whatever whatever so if you're GNA do it
using window of opportunity as an
example if you're gonna do Groundhog Day
you embrace it you you say okay we're
doing Groundhog Day so but we're going
to turn it on we're just going to make
it the Stargate version and we're going
to have it have meaning for you know at
by the end it's not just oh we've lived
the same day over and over and over
again um you know that that last scene
those last scenes with Malachi I can't
believe I remember that character's name
either um and uh and Jack about letting
go they resonate in Jack's own life yeah
you know it's it's it's funny and it's
great but it's it's you know it's a
Trope
that that you know we put our own you
know our own spin to we made the
Stargate version of that Trope I think
generally yeah we come to the consensus
that Stargate does that the best because
of that so well I think selfishly we
love that episode because that's where
we named ourselves from is our three fry
short of a happy short of a Happy Meal I
I I figured that very appreciative of
this
episode Christina do you have uh another
question you know well someone already
asked about the furlings in this space
and so I'm going to be sensitive that
because that was such a great answer to
it
um Let Me In My Mind put this the right
way or ask this the right
[Music]
way because I've heard you talk a lot
about this community and like feeling
this attachment with like Lawrence and
the companion and I don't think just
taking appealb back from like the
Stargate space of it I would just love
to hear like what does the community
mean to you because like we're having
this chance with like everyone coming
together from decades old to newer and
just I don't think maybe there's an
awareness of how much we all love and
adore like what you've done for this
community and who you are in this
community for us and I'd love to hear
from you what this community has has
done for you I'm I'm always surprised
I'm I'm always blown away when people
Express how much the show means to them
personally and how much they they give
me credit for that and I always go don't
give you're giving me too much credit
you're you're I yeah I was I was you
know at the chair at the end of the
table but the table was full of people
you know really smart creative people
who who uh deserve uh props for
everything that they did on the show and
uh
the here's a little metaphor for you um
I also want to move on myself right I
also consider myself an artist who
who wants to come up with a new show and
does a new show and and I'm pitching new
stuff all the time so so Travelers was
was uh to me a completely different
departure but when the Stargate fandom
embraced it was that was lovely for me
that was like I was like oh I I I get a
sense of Stargate in in in Travelers and
that's because I suppose my writing has
has a uh you know a a style and and uh
and travelers was in that style so that
was lovely that was lovely the other the
other the only other metaphor I want to
give you I I went and saw Peter
Gabriel in concert and the audience
loved him it was like a whole Arena full
of people who adore Peter Gabriel and I
was one of them and everybody was
listening to his new album and going
this is good yeah this is really good
this is terrific this is terrific and
then when one of his old hits came on
everybody went nuts and he recognized
yeah I know this is the reason you love
me and that's and and you know as an
analogy you know I know whatever I do
now I'm trying to continue to be an
artist and I hope it's really really
good but I know that fandm and and the
community are gonna you know I'm the
Stargate guy so thank you for that it's
a badge I will wear with honor well
thank you so much Brad for talking to us
it's been a a wonderful opportunity um
and thank you for being here for
everybody today I'm it's such an
exciting event it's a great idea well
it's good idea you had me thank oh oh
thanks you thank you Christina and
Rebecca amazing I'm actually sweating
backstage I'm like typing to everyone oh
man they're asking so good questions I
have to like reformat everything now
so um speaking of good questions it's
now David and the dial the gate segment
David's gonna stump me I know
it
[Music]
God I love these logos they've just done
such a great job yeah they're good need
to reach out to whoever this is and say
I need some help over here how are you
I'm very well thanks you David how are
you I'm good I went to John Williams uh
live at the Hollywood Bowl oh wow like
five six years ago yeah just it was just
one of those um uh bucket list items and
the whole night was euphoric and he
finished with the Imperial March and the
the whole place the entire night was
just insane but when that played it was
like the the whole place turned upside
down and I'm so glad to hear that you
also recognize it's it's a reason why
you're here that uh what Stargate means
to us is also what it means to you you
know it's it's you can still come up
with new great shows like Travelers and
new ideas but at the same time you know
we can still go back and and love this
thing that you created with all these
amazing people for 17 Seasons
so yeah it's it's
uh 17 seasons is a lot a giant chunk of
my life so um I can't uh you know and I
would never turn my back on it you know
the desire to create different kinds of
art uh uh you know new shows is just
because my brain just I just keep coming
up with stuff and whether or not I I may
be retired you never know but I I'm hope
hopefully I'm not and um and I get
another chance uh I thought that was
going to be Stargate for a little while
uh and I and I went I really want to do
this sure sure you can do this I
realizing that I that I was going to not
please everybody and there was still
going to be people this is the target
you we want and and so I you know I uh
but I still accepted the you know the
the challenge if you will and because
they called me and uh and then to not
for for for to not be doing it I'm also
okay with that I'm completely sanguin
with about it because um
because you know somebody El somebody
had to take over eventually
anyway have you seen the
Orville the show yeah yeah of course
yeah and that we're hoping to see season
four but it was finished in such a way
in season 3 that I as as a huge fan of
it was even like if this is it that's
okay and I've always felt that way about
you know sg1 but not for Atlanta
Universe because they were ripped from
us in terms of fandom and I will I will
repeat that SGU uh as one of the earlier
folks said is my favorite show so that
really hard I that was a tough one it
was a tough one I I mean and I dug in my
heels when when they suggested that we
end it and I ultimately I I'm probably
one of the few I love the ending of that
season two I just love the I love the
music CU that Joel did speaking of John
Williams will you tell me about that
call with
Joel playing over the pi too
hard he he uh he played It For Me on
piano live and
uh I miss him I miss him a lot I met him
twice and the first time that me he said
give me a
hug it was one of the last times I spoke
to him that's that's why it's so sad and
it was such a good queue and to this day
it hunts me but but as an episode as an
ending of an episode it's beautiful I
mean it was a beautiful season finale
and if it because it ended up being a
series finale I still think it's
beautiful uh do I wish we had an
opportunity to continue absolutely in
fact I start started writing a movie
that that uh a sort of a rescue mission
movie where uh you know characters from
Atlantis and sg1 went to visit went
to um save uh the destiny and I thought
well let's wrap it up at least in that
way and uh and then when I realized or
when I found out that MGM really had no
interest in in doing that uh it was uh
it was a bit heartbreaking but we kept
the setup right
we kept the set up for the longest time
and then it was okay we can't afford to
keep the lights okay let's take down the
lights and then it was like so and then
and and when I walked into that empty
State I never I couldn't watch some take
said done so I walked into the empty
stage it's really sad
too yeah no and I'm thankful that you
guys pulled pieces from that for
travelers because so pieces of of
destiny were in you know that show that
was a big deal Brad what what can we do
to get Joel's music out to people I have
been beating the drama when I was there
as a freelancer for MGM I was like what
can we do to get this music out who has
i i i his widow I mean possibly possibly
but I mean I I when the Continuum
score I can't even remember what it was
I think it was the Continuum score uh
when it was released uh the I talked to
the music guy and I said it should all
be released it's MGM music so it'll end
up being Amazon music uh department and
it just needs to be them the truth is
his music is so so
great um it it elevated the show yep
beyond the
show it it's I I don't mean to belittle
the show but without that without his
expertise uh he made it he made the show
better than it was just just because his
music was so
amazing and uh and I can hear cues in my
head like I can
play uh the window of
[Laughter]
opportunity and I remember the first
time I heard that I went oh God that's
perfect he's got it he would listen to a
day one mix and Joe would send me Joel
would send me individual cues and I
would just listen to the music uh
independent of a picture and you know
because I I mean our interaction was
pretty constant and
um but I didn't spot with him I didn't
say oh music should go here I said I'm
not GNA tell you what to do with where
where the music should go you're Joel
Goldsmith
man it was great I miss it absolutely
and like I I I'm the same about that
last piece of uh music from the show I
think it's the best piece of music that
he ever wrote because it was just you
could feel in his heart that it was the
culmination of his love for that for
that franchise and I have a hard time
rewatching that last 15 minutes because
it someone just take someone just take a
steak knife to my heart man and just cut
all the way through because that's what
it feels like so there are there are fan
versions of that online because they
couldn't get it released fans have gone
and recreated it and it's just beautiful
it's he's he's there no one will
duplicate him no one no no no um
Stargate ended up in cluding a number of
episodes which turned out to
be prophetic especially unlike the
technological front re revisions I am
constantly referencing right now because
we know that it's coming we know that
wireless integration at some point will
be a part of our society in the next
hundred years that's it we're going to
be plugged in um and neuralink I think
is the birth pangs of that are there any
stories um which you felt turned out to
to hit closer to home than you expected
that's interesting that you should say
that because my my uh my producing
partner uh Carrie mud uh we we did
Travelers together uh she kept say as
she asked me the same question and and
then the same thing happened in
Travelers uh we did a CO we did a an
episode that that speaking of prophetic
that everybody thought oh my God they
predicted coid and well it was it was
just a a pandemic episode and and and
then a pandemic happened but uh but you
know the there are lots of little things
in uh in like in Universe the uh I was
worried about the batteries and and I
said well why don't we just create this
this thing we'll call it a charging
plate and and you put your flashlight on
it and then and then the batteries work
again we wrote that scene into the thing
and now I put my phone down on a now we
did not invent that it's it's it was
just simply an easy way of getting
around the fact that we were out of
batteries and and it made sense clearly
the were Engineers working on that
technology before but it is kind of cool
absolutely it is yeah yeah
uh were there any others that stand
out in Travelers I mean in Travelers yes
but uh but in sg1 I uh I mean we're
going way way back a lot of the
technology that we came up with uh was
naturally going to happen you
know urius TSH wanted to know why did
you do soak are so dirty apus totally
stole his Arc and I think this goes back
to a larger question of what audiences
expect of the villains in terms of of
leadup because it was certainly a shock
to me when I was watching okay a moon
just took him out so that's probably
over um did was that and I spoke with
Jonathan a little bit about this was was
it's specifically to soar and in like a
larger conversation of villains in
general was it an expect like okay we're
done with this guy let's throw the
audience a curveball and nuke him and
return to Aus which was not necessarily
expected certainly Darren didn't expect
it he created gate world because of it
I'm sure he'll talk about that well I
honestly I I I honestly don't remember
the the the rationale in the moment
um but you know we we would sometimes it
might have even just been
practical uh
but I also like apus was an our ongoing
guy so it was It was kind of cool to
bring him back too um what did Jonathan
say I don't remember he was he was very
much like you know the the character is
fulfilled his purpose we're moving on
that was okay that probably was that was
probably it yeah yeah because you could
have gone on with him for a couple more
years yeah well abely I mean that the
there were so many ancient gods that the
gold were we're adopting uh we we could
jump I mean we could just have new ones
so if I may insert really quickly here
one of one of the promises of of the
original or or the the uh what's posited
in early on in season one is that there
the GS either were here on Earth or they
took on the personas of of our gods and
which which do you think it was in the
final
analysis I think that they came and and
took uh transplanted hum transplanted
humans to their own worlds and adopted
from there their gods okay and and maybe
there maybe it went both ways to a
certain extent okay I mean the pyramid
if it was a you
know we didn't invent that concept I
mean that that was we borrowed that from
the movie and then expanded upon it
that's all okay uh but that's to me what
it was and and uh they were like hey I
if you think about it it's a pretty
powerful way to uh
to take over a culture you know to uh to
say yeah yeah I am that guy you know
really yeah I can fly and I have a
spaceship okay well you're a God then
you are that God makesense wormal
extremists we just rewatched uh
uh the episode where and I'm 40 now and
these these names are going away but uh
the episode where they go through the
the Stargate and they find a religious
Society who you know they're uncovering
the gate and it's not it's going against
religion and we had the conversation in
the episode you know what if Christ came
back you know and said that he was he
was who he said he was what percentage
of the population would just be like no
I don't believe it this is this is a
this is not real you know how far do you
do you how far are you willing to go you
know to prove something wrong that you
know you know this this can't be real
someone's got to be faking this with our
news and everything else now so well
what is the uh there's there's two
things uh that come to mind one is a is
the Arthur C Clark quot quot uh any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic or
Supernatural by by extension and the
other one is a is a I can't remember
what season it was of the original uh
TNG series uh where uh a woman po an
alien posed as the god of a culture's do
Audra there you go see yeah you knew it
but I remember the episode and and that
is a that is that structure I mean
it's that's there it is right in one
episode you know Harvey and Todd The
Wraith if you go back and change it
would you have added a full opening to
SGU opening
credits Oh I thought you were talking
about the right ver that's the person's
name got it yeah uh what hary
um uh there was a Harvey no uh no I
loved it uh
I
here's a funny thing this is a true
story uh sci-fi wanted us to shorten the
the credit sequence for Atlantis you
probably know this story but uh but Joel
had written this gorgeous beautiful
piece and and the one thing that allowed
me to win the argument basically as we
were still in the midst of arguing about
whether or not it should be a short
thing or a long thing which Joel got
nominated for an
Emmy and I thought H okay well do you
want to cut the Emmy nominated music
down to nothing okay I guess we could do
that so that work very well in my uh
it's television changes and it and
evolves and and even in Travelers you
know um uh I remember Carrie and I uh
going over about how long the opening
sequence should be and Netflix said you
know any opportunity you get you you
create for somebody to to to turn it off
or fast forward or you know just switch
channels
um that's what short titles help you
with you know so we made it 18 seconds
sure I have one question for you
remaining it's kind of like a yes or no
if you want to expound on it it's up to
you but throughout the Run of universe
there appeared to be omnicient aliens
interfering with Destiny's path such as
when they created a solar system where
some of the destiny settled and were
later miraculously returned to the ship
to end their lives again with their
colleagues did this race have anything
to do with Destiny's ultimate
Mission well it could have it certainly
could have I mean we wanted there to be
a a race of beings that at least rivaled
the Ancients yeah uh but not necessarily
the Ancients uh in fact not the Ancients
uh they were pretty powerful yeah and
and they were clearly trying to
understand us and try to do things for
us uh but for me we wanted them to be as
powerful as as as more advanced than we
are as we are to you know ants so
um uh yeah we wanted and they didn't
have to be omniscient and they didn't
have to tie into the to the last you
know to the to the Arc of the the show
as we saw it but they certainly could
have okay Brad thank you for doing this
and it means so much that all of us can
get to here to to sit down with you
together and i' I'd love to get you on
dial the gate next year Well I I'm glad
we had this and uh and and uh and I knew
you were going to ask a question that
that made me choke up or
something you're the Barbara Walters of
interviewers David Barbara Wawa there
you go thank you Brad thank you thanks
David um I am frantically now Crossing
off my questions another great interview
oh man wonder if there's any material
left but you know next up is aen uh with
gate
[Music]
World hey hello I have the same
experience but kind of being towards the
end of the queue listening to all these
great interview questions and just
enjoying everything as it goes and my
question Just Wind me up I can talk for
15 minutes you don't have to worry about
it I I folks might know if they've been
around for a while the gate World used
to visit the set annually when you guys
were in production and I you know I was
a kid I was really nervous walking
around you know talking with Joe
Flanigan and Tory higginson and Amanda
Tapping and then we'd go upstairs to the
writer's room and and you were the
easiest interview because I could just
walk into your office plop down on the
couch and say Brad what's going on you
would talk for 20 minutes yeah that's
make a wind up toy I can just uh pull my
string and off I go yep yep yep yep yep
yep yep well I I want to ask you first
about your craft because uh right I've
been following your work since the utter
limits all the way through years and
years of Stargate and through Travelers
as you've moved through your career and
had those different experiences what are
the elements that you would say make up
a good writer
room uh how are the writers the
different writers rooms that you've been
a part of how have they differed from
each
other that's a that's an interesting
question um the the other limits
was it was because we were each writing
individual
stories it there was never an arc that
we had to worry about tying into so
basically I would go into Jonathan's or
Scott's or Manny's office back in season
one and say how about this and they
would say that's cool let's pitch that
to trilogy trilogy was the uh uh the uh
the studio I no not the studio they MGM
was a studio but they were the
production entity that had sold the
outer limits to uh
uh to MGM so I would I then we'd have to
pitch that and it would just be like a
document what about this and and they
had and it was they would just go yes no
yes no and we would either do write an
outline and and and it would get
developed further or you know I would
just write the damn thing and say here
how about this and we got so desperate
on the utter limits uh because we were a
little behind when I started on that
show um but John and I were very good at
working together in spinning story
Jonathan and I and and we did that on
the Auto Limit together so when we came
to uh
Stargate uh the writer's room was catch
as catch can it was we were we were
never all together for any length of
time uh except at the beginning of the
Season uh in a real room enough long
enough to to even call it a writer's
room it was like Hey guys can we steal
an hour you know and we'd all sit and
we'd spend the idea or what whatever we
needed to spin and and that kind of just
carried over into the rest of the the
rest of the show um except for the
beginning of the season and the end of
the season when we actually sat were
able to sit down we we did not have a
structured writer room in the same way
that that for example I was able to do
on Travelers um with Travelers uh and
and in and it was a giant we we had
three or four weeks and and then all
through prep it was me and the writers
spinning
stories uh breaking stories on the white
board all of which we did in in uh
Stargate but but in a more structured
way in a more in a more all at once way
uh and it part of it was because John
and I were also producing The Outer
Limits uh so we just didn't have time we
just we were like grabbing time to to
put stuff on a whiteboard
and um and uh break stories and uh we
got better at it and we got more uh we
started devoting more time to it when uh
but and I have to say
um there is no more fun place than a
writer's room uh when you're on fire
there is it's
just especially if when you have people
as funny as Martin gero and making you
Paul moly just making you cry laughing
at at at you know anything that uh that
you know we're discussing and uh in
context or out of context and and uh
that continued into Travelers I uh it is
just so much fun to spin story it can be
frustrating as hell it can be it can be
painful because you're you know you're
you know there's something there but
this thing is in the way or or whatever
and and and you know you don't have an
act four it's always act four that's J
would
say but um uh but it's so satisfying
when you when you when you come away and
drive home and think and go yeah that
was good that was a it was exhausting it
can be really exhausting but so much
fun um and then and then what I learned
another thing I learned on Travelers uh
uh was you you you uh you break a story
and and and this what we started doing
we broke the story again we would wipe
it off the board and do it again
amazingly when you try to do it a second
time all the glue and spit that was
holding together the version one reveals
itself and you and it quite often is you
know different and wa and and it and uh
it's like the second pass on on a on a
on any draft and and it's but by
starting from scratch like it's a proof
of concept a proof that oh yeah this is
a good story or this isn't a good story
uh but there is no more there's no more
fun place in the world than you know a
bunch of people in a writer's
room one of the really fun stories that
that you contributed to the Stargate
world was season 4S 2010 and season 5es
2001 uh we've heard Whispers over the
years that that the Ashen were going to
be a Trilogy so I wonder if you could
talk us through the the Genesis of the
idea how did the Ashen come about and
how this idea gets developed in the
writer's room and then why didn't that
third one come about what was in the way
that you couldn't it it could have it
could have and I could have probably
come up with another aen story uh
because they would have been angry with
what we did to them after 200 one after
that episode
um uh I I but I laugh and smile every
time you say it because Rob was not a
fan I mean he liked the episodes he
liked what but he didn't like them as a
villain he didn't like the slow game the
long game that that the aen played out
like you know what oh they're gonna
starve us out and Rob went oh oh my God
they're not growing corn is not a
great and I again funny writers or a
moment but
um but uh the I I mean 2010 is arguably
my my favorite of my own episodes
because mainly because Andy mck did such
a great job directing it and it was one
of his first uh directing assignments uh
the last
Act is is like a feature and Joel's
music again was spectacular but
um this the story that sort of came to
mind in terms of the Ashen coming
directly without a Stargate to worth
ended up being uh a component of one of
the uh directed Med movies indirectly I
mean I can't even say it's the same but
it just felt like it stepped on it so I
think that the uh that that was the
reason uh and I may even be wrong about
that I mean because you were already
planning the sort of Earth invasion for
a different race for a different
storyline yeah something like
that that's good um one of the things
that I do on gate world is we sort of
think of ourselves as chronicling the
history of the show the history of
production which is why I ask all these
sort of backward looking questions I
think a lot of people who have been
around for a while they know that there
were a couple of movies that didn't get
made Joe and Paul's Stargate Extinction
script for Atlantis and I think it was
you and Carl were working together on
Stargate Revolution is that right yeah
that's right and and the truth is they
they not only didn't get made they they
were really relatively early in their uh
in their development it's not like we
were we had a script that we could have
shot we were still you know that we had
first drafts I think and they were
something we were planning to do like
six months down the
road and uh and it and it was because of
the uh Continuum in Arc of Truth did
very well
for uh for MGM as director video movies
and and uh the market for a director it
was it was a good business model it was
a it was a really solid business model
and it was a way especially for Atlantis
to keep going
um because the television model was was
uh arguably going to be difficult
um and and we love doing it I Rob and I
Rob loved making AR truth I loved making
Continuum and uh and I thought man I
could make two of these a year for for a
while this would be great and uh and it
was it was purely the the the collapse
of the DVD Market um uh that that that
triggered the the uh sidelining of those
projects and it began as could you just
like put a hold on development for for a
couple weeks as because we're getting
some numbers here that are literally a
month later yeah I think we need to put
a like a like just just a stop on
development on this for for now and just
see how it and then a month later forget
it there's no way we can make these and
Continuum was one of the last movies MGM
released director DVD that made money
yeah what I really want to ask about is
the movie that uh didn't get as far and
most people probably don't know about
which is the one you mentioned earlier
in the live stream uh a sort of combo
team up of of characters from all three
shows uh to give some kind of conclusion
to Destiny's Story how far did that get
into development and what can you share
with us about what it be I just started
typing Darren I I I I asked uh my uh
my boss at MGM who was a huge Stargate
fan and was kind of mortified by the
fact that all this was
happening uh and I said look we have
many millions of dollars worth of sets
here that are going to have to get
packed up and and and and basically
discarded
and if I can get a script in your hands
quickly enough I bet I can get the cast
of SGU and and and bring aboard Enough
cast members from the other show that
uh that I could at least give us a a
two-hour movie to wrap it up or a
90-minute movie to to wrap up SGU and
finish the story that we were trying to
tell and
I I had a I I pitched him the rough idea
I had for it and it was rough I mean I
you know I was typing as fast as I
could and my process is not like like
what I did didn't I didn't whiteboard it
I just had this sort of structure in my
head and
and concept of the characters from the
other series that I was going to bring
in and I and I started writing it
started laying it out and uh and uh it
started with u you know it started with
McKay and you know it began recognition
that Destiny was in
trouble and um and there you
know I I don't want to go into the plot
details but the the the the the at the
end of the day before I really got into
any like two weeks into the the process
I found out it's not GNA happen and and
uh and even even as we were going
through it it was could you do it for
this number could you do it for this
number could and then it got to the
point where
look I'm already I've already taken my
own my own producing fee out of the
budget but I can't take visualg you do
it with hand
you know we can't it there's a there's
there comes a time where where the
desire to finish something doesn't line
up with the financial resources to do it
and that's that was where it was already
heading when when I found out they're
not they're not interested they're not
the new regime was just not remotely
interested yeah that's my memory is that
it was it was 2011 I think by my
reporting yeah uh so this would have
been after the bankruptcy after there
was a new set of people inside
MGM yes it was it was a it was I was
writing uh but we had left the sets up
um out out of the hope that we
could do that and we we funded it with
uh I can't remember how we funded it we
had an underd That season and the the
truth is it it you know it probably cost
MGM a few bucks to to for that show of
good faith and the hope that we could
keep the keep uh the the flame alive if
you will and uh it was that was sad
because I was trying really hard I mean
I I just you know I had been spoiled for
so many years Darren of of of them
saying well come up with another one
well come up with another one and and
and to have something that was not only
out of my control but out of the control
of the executives that MGM I was working
with a structured bankruptcy means
everybody goes home and the new a new
regime comes in and takes hope yeah and
the new regime was not interested
yeah well uh we're on our one minute
countdown there's Lawrence let me ask
you one last question kind of looking
forward right we've we've been pushing
hard for a lot of years for for your
involvement in the next project and if
not your involvement then then the
universe that you helped to build to to
continue on with that continuity um
you've always said in in interviews like
here at the companion and on your Reddit
Ama that you think one of the core ideas
about Stargate is that it's us these
characters are relatable they're
temporary uh so jmfg on gate World asks
do you believe that that here and now is
still the secret ingredient to gate
world's future success even under this
new paradigm of binge watching
serialization streaming series and then
I'll just add to that by asking in your
mind under you know in new creative
hands is there room for something like a
Stargate the Next Generation that's
actually said a few decades in the
future the answer is is is absolutely
yes um because
um because frankly one of the
difficulties and I and I say this as
somebody who would probably benefit uh
from a in Cannon uh continuation
uh the I get the rationale for a reset
but a next gener generation is sort of a
happy medium because it is sort of a
reset it is enough in the future that
that
um uh that the that the world is
different but the one thing another
thing that happened in Stargate and I
know Lawrence you're probably uh but if
you're next I can make you wait
right I made you a promise at 89 minutes
and we are at 92 so we'll go fast we'll
go fast Darren please the the the thing
that you can't do uh if you do a next a
future Earth is is you know walk around
Earth the way it is right now you know
you have to be Earth has advaned and I
say this I had this conversation with my
producing partner Carrie mud uh about
another idea that we had and I said it's
so hard to do the future you can't you
if you do something set 80 years from
now you know what do the cars look like
you know what what does what does Earth
look like you know what are the social
norms but are the politics you can't you
can't it's it's a whole other World
building in addition to the Sci-Fi
component right and everything has to be
shot on sound
stages yeah pretty much I
mean and you know uh honestly Star Trek
is doing a pretty good job of it uh of
modern Earth they really are uh uh and
uh but they have a they have a lot of
money they have a lot of money so if you
do that then my my suggestion is have a
lot of
money does that make sense yeah good
good
answer uh thank you it's always a joy
thank you thank you Darren it it's good
to see you you I appreciate the decades
long support well let's do it again
okay thanks Brad we will I guess roll
into our segment I don't know if Tommy
has a graphic he might for us he might
not I bet he
does
[Music]
I have my companion
t-shirt I love it I I have been thinking
about making companion merch for myself
and they just think that's kind of
cheesy isn't it so
I hey I I still have Stargate hats I I I
always grabbed a couple every year well
next time I uh next time as in the first
time we actually meet in person you know
we can we can wear buddy buddy buddy you
know Stargate hats yeah yeah if you make
companion hats though make make me a
visor because I don't wear when I'm
golfing I I uh you know what actually
okay so we have these community members
that we call Companion Champions you
know they help us out they give us
feedback Etc and I recently saw this
really awesome line of um Adidas like
golf shirts and stuff and I thought you
know what both the the men and the women
would look so good in these almost like
these kind of elite uniforms if they had
these like Adidas you know kind of
companion um kind of like almost like
uniforms I guess so I'll I'll send you
one if we end up you know printing out
that line if you end up doing it sure
sure yeah yeah I mean I think I think I
think we will yeah yeah yeah not not a
triple extra large like the like the one
you sent me last time just to just to it
wasn't me that was yeah I was just going
to go Double L no Kidd no no no no no
we'll work out those details um but um
yeah so I think one thing I mean you you
know this a lot about the companion is
that um I don't think about it as really
like me or just Tommy or even like you
and Rebecca Etc it's not just like kind
of the people who kind of work on the
project and work here but it really is
you know all of the members they and
they feed in they vote and you know they
you know pick screens for uh scenes for
like Stargate Ai and things like that
and so um I wanted to actually give um
some time to one of our our members that
we absolutely love and you might even
recognize her her name is Mara and she
was at your um M your master class in
writing about a year ago so Tommy if you
can bring up Mara um to ask a
question he Mar I recognize you hi it's
nice to see you you
too um I had a question if you had
switched lives to one of your characters
for a day who would it be and how do you
think you would do at each other's
jobs at each other's jobs that's so
interesting
um I you know my instinct is
uh I don't know why I think of rush I
guess because he was in charge and and I
was in char charge for a long
time and and and also because he would
have no time at all for my job he would
be uh come up with your silly stories
and
uh um I I mean my my first instinct of
that question too is Daniel but uh I
know only one language and it's English
and I barely know that one and uh I
think Danny would be very good at
storytelling because uh he would just
borrow from the ancient histories of
Earth uh and come up with uh some good
old stories I'm
sure Mara I think you're also wearing a
very special shirt that we were all
project of you can yeah you remember
that the
star the dog yeah dog the dog mcgillion
that's right that's hilarious yeah yeah
that was funny it freaked me out for
just a second but now I get then I
remembered that's great Mara thank you
so much did I answer your question Mara
was it good yeah okay good thank
you oh we love Mara Mara's so great I'm
glad I do remember her from the from the
writer uh from the yeah I kind of wish
that was broadcast there was like such
good information uh there I think a lot
of people would really benefit so you
know we've been kind of in about it and
kind of sharing some of those those
lessons um I mean you know recently um
well you introduced us to Amanda right
the first time we ever did an AMA like
three years ago and obviously Amanda's
been you know a really huge part of you
know what we've been doing we've been
doing these events called embracing
mental health as a fandom we do some
like charity work sometimes um I'm just
kind of catching you up a little bit I
guess and uh last weekend also uh you'll
know that we did juwel States a Ma and
was raising money for Wildfire you know
relief and and you asked a question
there all right I remember that about
last week I I cut all the checks to the
Charities and really this summer you
know we haven't really caught up since
this summer but we I cut checks for
$177,000 and it's m like Mara and you
know Gemma and Vicky and all the other
people that have come to these events or
supported or donated it's like I mean
genuinely I was just thinking this is
like you know Ed McMahon big
check you know it is I didn't know you
know yeah when we're thinking about
doing maybe we'll raise a thousand bucks
here or there but like 17,000 that's a
lot that's a lot of money yeah it's
pretty incredible fabulous yeah that's
what community is right I mean that's
the difference between a bunch of people
and community and that's what you've
managed to develop with the companion
it's it's terrific oh thanks thanks Brad
but yeah I mean it's also what you
developed right you you created this
show and yet we could talk about mental
health we could talk about Wildfire
relief and cooking and really you know
it's it's the bond of of Stargate but we
can just talk about all these other
subjects because you know we got we got
something to fall back on that connects
us yeah that's the Touchstone that's the
Touchstone between us all yeah yeah good
it's a classy thing um so we got another
video question um really it's a video
comment I think from maybe your biggest
fan um and he had a few words for the
celebration well hello
Bradley
um well I if you can
guess who I
am then you're uh step up on
me here let me help you
yeah it's me it's
Rick listen hap what is it
birthday some kind of celebration for
you buddy you deserve
it
what no no no I don't take Direction
well all right buddy you know I love you
um but I'm starting to
love Felix better than you more than you
but uh it'll be shortlived I'll get back
to
you um congratulations on whatever this
is see
you I love that guy he's
great he it was so kind of it was so
kind of him to you know come his hair
before he came on and L pretty good he
looked we didn't have to do any kind of
editing or anything
look great he kills me he just kills
me I had a hard time hearing it but I I
got the gist we'll send it to you we'll
send it to you afterwards okay please do
yeah yeah um well I mean kind of
speaking to to Rick and a year ago we
did that Stargate Legacy with me you and
Rick um and it was around star and my
mom and your mom and your mom don't
leave her out she was the she was the
hit of that particular show oh
absolutely absolutely yeah um and the
painting was just the whole thing the
whole thing was was awesome yeah I love
I love that event um you know we're kind
of continuing this as a I'm kind of like
jumping ahead but we're doing this again
next week right another Stargate Legacy
uh but this time with window of
opportunity so we'll talk about that in
a second but um yeah hopefully hopefully
there'll be lots of touching moments in
that one too but getting to Children of
the Gods and a year ago um I I had
pinged you because I remember in that
conversation you know we talked about uh
effectively in in the pilot and that
script you know the new Stargate and so
I just want to make sure I get the
oh um you you kind of called it right it
was like a gleaming metal Stargate
different than any we've ever ever seen
before and is entirely of human design
and and um and I think I remember you
were describing it to Rick you were
saying um you know it would kind of
speed up a little bit different right
it'd be like chong chong chong chong
chong chong chong chong chong like yeah
that's right idea yeah can you describe
a little bit more about like what you
were thinking with the new Stargate well
we have we have retrofitted and updated
and and used uh uh ancient Technologies
and and and Stargate
Technologies uh all through all through
all three shows and
and each series had its own you know
iconic Stargate uh SG was the original
one found in the desert Atlantis was the
digital one uh the which was had a
different look and feel and texture and
of course uh the one aboard Destiny was
the oldest of all and and uh and had
that cool I just love the design James
Robins designed that one and and uh and
it looked like the destiny itself the
chevron's
within this the Stargate where that
shape but so I thought we needed a new
one and I thought well let's we can't
find one so uh because one of my goals
was to go to yet another galaxy I'm
giving way too much information again
and to do that we would have needed
another uh a human built purpose-built
Stargate and I just thought it would be
really cool not to take work away from
Gary Jones but to not have to go Chevron
one encoded at you know a snail's pace
but to to just have the sequence
initiate and and to have the whole thing
spin really like powerfully
and and then K I thought that would be
really
cool have to hit the button or something
right maybe they'll do it maybe they'll
do something like it I don't know who
knows and like would you imagine it if
it's GNA be a human-made Stargate is it
necessarily materials from Earth is it
like other planets that we visited
already I would have to sit with a our
production designer before I started
talking about that stuff but I I I had
this I had this image of of actual glass
like of actual parts of it being uh
transparent and being able to see
through components of it and and uh and
and I just wanted it to look powerful
and human built I just wanted it to have
those
qualities uh and Carter would have her
hands all over it right it would have
been her
brainchild that would I mean that feels
really obviously really modern right
that kind of yeah would look
great yeah don't make me
cry we'll we'll cry together we're gonna
figure this out figure this
out um so I had a question kind of a
little bit uh uh where actually behind
you is the Guinness World Record I
believe would you this oh sorry I'm not
would you mind sharing that because
that's the kind of that's the that's the
Stargate Guinness World Record
right so this is uh this is the uh
certificate the actual certificate from
the Guinness uh I think that record has
since been
beat but
uh so
yeah this is
uh this is me this is me uh oh yeah
outside of a fire jet that I actually
got to fly which is very cool
Incredible and this is my photograph uh
as a gift from Eric mccormac of me and
my producing partner Carrie mud uh her
uh giving her feelings to that
photograph yeah these are these are some
of my precious uh things in my office
that I quite enjoy yeah no I mean I knew
I knew the the Guinness
sh for showing
[Laughter]
that um no I thought you know with with
this being Stargate celebration I
thought it'd be pretty cool for fans to
be able to see at least the Guinness
World Record I mean you know they I
guess in a small slash big way helped
make that happen I
guess uh you know it Thomas Cena Gibson
said basically said you know I think you
deserve a Guinness book of of uh Records
thing and I went really do we qualify
and she said yes and she basically just
called them and they went yeah
absolutely and so it happened it was
cool Thomas's work really oh very cool
um all right well I think our our 10
minutes are up Brad oh really as yeah as
as as promise it seems like I've only
been talking for a day and a half
Lawrence not to me we're down no not to
you not to you down to 11 viewers
there's only 11 people left oh no no no
we this we are among them hi Mom yeah
we're hitting record numbers actually um
I think I think it's almost actually to
the point of nearly a thousand I think I
was some people were were telling it up
over 800 people live that's that's great
hey everybody follow me on X or Twitter
or whatever it's called Brad
Travelers yeah I want to see I want to
see how many people follow me if I ask
them to yeah do it oh one more thing I
was gonna actually kind of update this
you on this and then kind of explain it
so I think it was two or three weeks ago
um Lawrence [__] and I so for those of
you who might not know Lawrence [__] um
actually built starg AI um one of the
projects that we all worked on together
and obviously Brad helmed um so so
Oxford invited Usher University invited
me yeah he told me about this yeah yeah
yeah and then I completely forgot I was
even going to parti because it would
have been great for you to be there oh
well yeah I was traveling I was I was I
was flying in the air all all over the
place at that time yeah now Tommy and I
went so Tommy's one of The Producers
here uh with Lawrence and you know it
was fun because obviously I very lucky I
went to Oxford and I've been in that
building a million times and this kind
of thing and then it struck me um Not
only was it at the business school later
Lawrence gave a reference to the project
in the sheldonian and the sheldonian is
like that kind of 500 600 year old style
building where
genuinely um people like JRR
tolken
myself um Bill Clinton you know heads of
States um you know fantasy writers
people who discovered DNA we all have to
matriculate and graduate there and it
was like it it hit me whoa Stargate and
AI is in the sheldonian and it's the
oldest it's the oldest school um in
English-speaking history you know and um
I guess I want to ask you one final
question in terms of Stargate and its
Legacy and like I guess being in Oxford
I don't know do you have any thoughts on
that and
I let's just say I would not have been
qualified to get into Oxford
on any
subject um I I'm envious of the uh of
the experience uh that you had going
there in the just in the oldness of the
place of the you know knowing the minds
that have taught and have learned there
it's to have Stargate even discussed in
that context seems kind of remarkable to
me there were a ton of fans a ton of
fans came back and said like oh my
goodness I didn't know I didn't know
Stargate AI existed uh I love Stargate
growing up you know all of that uh there
was it was definitely like you would be
at any convention or you know just
talking to fans it was the same thing
there so that's cool that's really cool
you got you got a lot of uh yeah fans
everywhere I it's it's you never know
right and uh you you you meet somebody
and and you know at a dinner party or
wherever and and they you know I said
Alo you're a writer you made anything
that uh that I made before and I always
say Travelers because that's the most
recent they go no I've never watch that
well and then Stargate Stargate and then
they'll then that's the whole evening
they just want to talk about
Stargate and then some people go yeah
I've seen that and and that's fine with
me it's not everybody's cup of tea but
it's really remarkable when a a genuine
fan uh gets going on it it's it's uh as
evidenced by
today yeah I had to like not look at the
comment section so I literally have 799
unread comments because it was coming in
so fast it was like distracting me from
hosting and like doing timing and
everything like that so yeah um I'm glad
it worked out and I'm glad I hope my
iPad was a suitable U replacement for oh
yeah the oh good yeah CL we're gonna
hopefully continue this conversation and
that's why we kind of try to keep our
segment short I think we've actually
gone long now so I've broken the trust
of all part Partners but um for everyone
else who wants uh to see us and and kind
of Stargate Legacy and Brad you know
talk about Stargate continue next
weekend next Saturday actually um yeah
we'll be talking about window of
opportunity uh Joseph meoi Paul mly they
all be back so hopefully you and and the
writing crew will be able to reminisce
and maybe shed some light on on the
episode cool
yeah and um yeah so just a kind of last
note about the companion and everything
else we're we're trying to do um events
basically every two weeks this has kind
of been an unusual time where last week
we had you know an event today and then
next week um and so hopefully people
like what we do and they kind of sign up
to us if they haven't heard of about us
before um and yeah and we got a pretty
cool offer going on right now so so
hopefully we'll see more members too
Brad at the next kind of live stream
it's pretty great companion is pretty
great there's a lot of lot of uh stuff
there there's a lot of good resources
and you know I've written essays for you
guys and there's a lot of there a
podcast there it's fun it's great I love
it nice all right so we're gonna bring
back in all of the um the other guests I
think some of them had to potentially
jump off but hopefully most of them will
it was just Christina that Dida okay
okay she has mom duties so yeah
absolutely yeah um so I wanted to just
say a final thank you to Brad obviously
a final thank you to everyone else who
has come and joined here um and I want
to just give everyone kind of one final
note I'll start with everyone at you
know one at a time um and so Rebecca I
don't know if you want to start um oh
wow on the spot uh thank you so much
Brad this has been amazing um I have the
job that I have now because of the
universe that you co-created so it's uh
it's much appreciated um and yeah that
that's what I have to say thank you so
much you're welcome and thank you thank
you I I love that you have a
job um Jay um Jay or Matt you know how
has this experience kind of been for for
you
too just mental it's it's it's not right
um I I don't know I think I told you
this Brad but you actually followed me
on Twitter on my birthday this year
so my kids bought me presents and I was
like yeah Brad R follow me on
Twitter that's a nice watch Brad right
followed me on Twitter
so I'm sorry I'm sorry I apologize to
your family I'm sure it was yeah my wife
hat hates you she's like who the hell is
this Brad right and why have you been
talking about him for the last four
hours but no it's just it's just crazy
that that you know I started my little
Channel talking about show I loved and
now I get to do things like this it's
amazing thank you just thank you for I
enjoy chatting with you too
Jay you see Co Matt do you have any
quick word or anything like that could
you just say yeah no no can you just say
shut up Matt for me just because
everyone in my thing has asked me to
tell you to do it
please sh up
M go go on Brad you can say it you can
say it it's okay no keep going I
he wants you to say shut up Matt I'm not
going to do that Jay I don't do that
it's a thing on our Channel I don't know
why it's a thing I know I
know no I just want to say I just want
to say thank you for for for creating or
co-creating the the show that I love um
thank you to everyone here for this shut
up I'm
kidding
yes sorry I'm
sorry I had to swing at that I'm sorry
buddy I it felt wrong but
uh well thank you for that Brad thank
you no thank you to everyone this has
been fantastic and good I'm glad shut up
Brad whoa no no no no no no it's okay
it's okay it's okay broad shoulders yeah
uh David I can only apologize I can only
apologize know it's uh I know it's mushy
and I and I told you this years ago but
it but it's true and my father and I are
very close but I was only allowed to
watch you know PBS and Star Trek when I
was growing up until like eight or nine
years old wasn't allowed cartoons or
anything like that and then it like
sci-fi is like a part of me and you know
I consider my sci-fi dads to be you know
rotenberry and Burman and Cooper and
Glassner and Wright so thank
you wow cool wow wow and thank for
finding me and making me a part of
something that I can continue to be
thankful for there's a segue for you
good segue yeah
Darren guys it's just amazing that we
keep doing that we get to do this uh so
I want to say thank you to the companion
thank you to sidk thank you to three
fries dial the gate this is kind of an
amazing thing that Stargate fandom is
this cool and that we have this kind of
platform and that we have the people who
made the the content that we love so
much sorry I'm not supposed to call it
content the art that we love so much uh
here and still willing to talk about it
all these years later so thank you Brad
for giving ush your time Stargate is an
becoming an intergenerational thing and
it has been for years right we've heard
stories for so many years about people
who introduce their kids to the show
well I finally introduced my kids to the
show on the umth rewatch and you know
what just last night we finished
Atlantis so we've watched two of your
three shows so far with my three kids
and now I get to have that experience of
sharing that that thing that I love so
much with them and that's always going
to be a part of our lives so thank you
oh thank you thank you I I love I love
hearing that and I love it when new
generations find a show that I started
over 25 years ago it's
remarkable all right well thank you
everyone thank all the fans for coming
too and and sending in all the questions
and uh like what Darren said please
follow gate World dial the gate
Sidetrack three fries short um you know
and if you want to come next weekend um
starget Legacy you could do that too on
the companion thank you Lawrence and
thank you comp great job great job I'm
glad it all worked
out awesome thanks all is
technologically quite difficult it is
yeah thank you to Rick and Rick yeah
yeah yeah okay I I really have to pay
now so I'm gonna go bye yeah see you
guys bye Brad